[Musique]
moi j'ai toujours rêvé évidemment
d'entrer dans la caverne d'ali baba
cette caverne d'ali baba en fait c'est
le musée de la civilisation québec qui
va hériter on parle concrètement c'est
la bibliothèque et l'atelier de l'auteur
culte
réjean ducharme qui est considéré comme
plusieurs le plus grands écrivains du
québec a certainement marqué toute une
époque que c'est pas terminé ses fans la
roche directeur du musée à québec bon
vous allez évoluer devoir faire le
ménage dans tout ça vous le dites 90 ans
à la caverne d'ali baba est ce que c'est
l'impression que vous avez eue quand je
passe il est entré vaut deux dit oui
c'est vrai que ça fait un peu caverne
d'ali baba parce que c'était un atelier
où personne n'entrait sauf lui
c'est la liquidatrice monique jean
l'indiqué elle de son rival connaissait
jean charest n'était jamais entré à ce
que pour vous dire que vraiment très peu
progresser sa conjointe y aller mais
personne d'autre alors c'était vraiment
son antre là où il crée là où il
écrivait l'os il crée c'est trop fou
littamé oeuvre en arts visuels qu'il
qu'il peignait où il a semblé plutôt
sous le nom de la plante
bon alors il voulait pas donner
d'entrevue qu'il y avait deux photos qui
a deux photos de cette galerie sont dans
l'atelier vous allez voir lyrique ne se
regardaient pas beaucoup aidé à
m'intégrer mais on les a par ailleurs qu
est-ce que quelqu'un qui est en
muséologie comme s'oublie de fer peut
comprendre ce qui se passait il était
était propos discret et il voulait pas
l'été secret secret et en ce sens elle
est devenue mythique parce que tellement
mystérieux donc un artiste un auteur
extrêmement important par ses pièces de
théâtre par ses romans bien sûr par ses
chansons aussi les chansons de
charlebois de pauline julier ses oeuvres
en arts visuels
donc c'est un personnage est un artiste
extrêmement important du québec
et quand la succession de réjean
ducharme nous a contacté pour nous dire
nous aimerions faire un legs les traits
particuliers offrir par certains objets
pas certains tableaux pas certains
livres mais si on offre
on offre tout le contenu de deux pièces
complètes
le bureau l'atelier avec la bibliothèque
et ça c'est une chance unique qui a très
peu d'endroits sur la planète où est-ce
qu'on a la chance de rentrer dans
l'intimité d'un créateur comme ça et on
va reconstituer sa moue musée de la
civilisation
2022 dans une exposition qu'on va
préparer là dans les prochains mois bon
bien des trucs comme ça on voit les
dictionnaires dans le moment aux pages
ouvertes
oui il est fait comme ça au moment de sa
mort quand c'était sur sa table de
chevet oui c'est le seul autre élément
qui ont appris qu'ils étaient pas dans
l'atelier mais qui était dans sa chambre
comme le lendemain de son décès lorsque
la succession des jeunes sa succession
sont entrés dans sa dans sa chambre
c'était là comme ça et on a voulu capter
ce moment et leur rendre à la population
ce que je faut comprendre aussi c'est
que peut-être ceux qui le connaissent
pas il écrivait pas en joie mais il crée
des beaux parcs il inventait des mots il
faisait d assemblage de mots parfois il
ay les parts avec les proverbes
l'inversé les proverbes
il aimait jouer avec la langue et c'est
dans ce sens notamment qu'il a été un
élément majeur d'extraordinaire sauf
qu'ils livrent pourrait vous donner des
pistes et ce pour les chercheurs
notamment oui dans la bibliothèque à
plus de 1000 livres ils sont presque
tous à noter souligné avec des mots en
marge il assuré
chercheurs vont pouvoir ouvrir et vous
savez qu'à des chercheurs partout sur la
planète en catalogne en france en
belgique en allemagne ou aux états unis
au canada bien sûr et au québec qui
s'intéressent à l'oeuvre de réjean
ducharme parce que c'est une oeuvre
majeure parce que très très inventive et
donc ces gens là vont pouvoir dans
quelques mois pologne peut immédiatement
parce qu'on a un petit travail à faire
avant
pouvoir entrer approcher au plus près de
l'esprit de revanche a le coffre
d'outils doit pas ressembler vraiment
vos techniciens de présentation où était
le cas le coffre d'outils d'un bricoleur
si on veut le dit dans le sens noble du
mot bricoleur oui c'était quelqu'un qui
s'amusait à ramasser des éléments et les
assembler dans son atelier pour créer
des oeuvres comme il le faisait en
assemblant des mots dans son habit
littéraire qu'est ce qu'il y avait dans
le coffre au marteau maillet tournevis
ce qu'on a dans un coffre à outils
standards ouais on al impression qu kaki
qui bricolait comme c'est un peu que ça
traînait autour ça lui permet de se
libérer l'esprit
ça faisait partie de sa démarche de
création de vouloir en fait moi je dis
qu'il faisait du développement durable
avant l'heure avant la mode lui
l'assemblée ramassés dans les rues dans
les années 70 dans les années 80 je lui
fais ça depuis deux mains toujours est
il crée des oeuvres avec ça parce que je
sais pas il aimait pas il est maire
reconstituer un univers à partir de
d'éléments disparates
c'est vrai que pour un musée de la
civilisation c'est une mine d'or c'est
exceptionnel c'est vraiment un hasard
que vous êtes un vrai trésor et qu'on va
essayer de partager le plus possible
avec la population et ça on en est bien
fier vous visez pour l'exposition 2022
mais évidemment les objets elles vont
rester pas toujours pour toujours dans
l'est dans la collection s'est
pérennisée est ce qu'on va souhaiter
c'est que cette exposition là puissent
circuler à weight être ailleurs au
québec et au canada
ailleurs sur la planète notamment en
france on l'espère parce que les c'est
un écrivain très important merci
beaucoup d'être grave nous en avoir
parlé ce matin mais merci à vous et
c'est vrai à retourner